the expression five times two to the T
gives the number of leaves in a plant as
a function of the number of weeks since
it was planted
what does to represent in this
expression so pause this video and see
if you can figure it out on your own all
right so let's look at the expression
right over here we could write it as
defining a function so we could say
leaves as a function of time is equal to
five times two to the T power and so we
could try this out a little bit if we
say well what is L of zero that would be
T equals zero that's when we're zero
weeks after it was planted so this is
right when it was planted well that's
five times two to the zero which is just
2 to the 0 is just 1 so it's equal to 5
and so when you see an exponential
expression or an exponential function
like this that is why this number out
here is often referred to as your
initial value initial initial value and
so let's explore this a little bit more
what is L of 1 what happens after one
week well that's going to be 5 times 2
to the first power or 5 times 2 so going
from the going from when it was planted
to the first week we are multiplying by
2 the number of leaves doubles well what
happens after two weeks the number of
leaves after 2 weeks well that's going
to be 5 times 2 to the second power well
that's the number that you had in the
first week times 2 so it looks like
every week we are doubling we are
multiplying by 2 and that's why this
number right over here which is what the
question is about the two this is often
referred to as the common ratio common
ratio because between any two successive
weeks the ratio between say week 2 and
week 1 is 2 week two is double week one
week one is double week zero so let's
see which of these choices actually
match up to that there were initially
two leaves in the plant well we know
that there weren't two leaves on the
plant our initial value was five
so let me cross that one out the number
of leaves is multiplied by two each week
well that's exactly what we just
described so I like that choice let's
look at the last one just for good
measure the plant was planted two weeks
ago well no they don't they don't tell
us anything about that this is a general
this is a general expression for T weeks
after it was planted so they're not
saying when it was actually planted so
we could rule that out and we feel good
about that second choice